every time that they come to a plant
after a few months or let's say one year
and see the progress that they have gone
through and many times and it's really
exciting I mean you you really feel that
you support and uh create better work
environment a better work experience for
the employees you hear about the results
and the improvements so of course it's
it's a great privilege an honor to be
able to lead such a such an organization
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctec
foreign
ERS let's talk about industry 4.0 meet
merav Grossman the CEO of advanced
manufacturing Institute
miravi is the CEO of the advanced
manufacturing Institute Ami in Israel
leading a unique program for digital
transformation in manufacturing
companies mainly small businesses
financed by the ministry of economy and
Industry mirov is happily married a
mother of three and holds a BSC degree
in information systems engineering and
an MBA in technology management with 30
years in senior positions in the
industry leading such an organization is
a privilege and mission for her
but you're you're you have such an
interesting Journey
um coming into your role and you know in
manufacturing and what you're doing
today and from the technion to
entrepreneur looking at diversity and
inclusion along the way manufacturing
and Factory in Industry 4.0 so I'm not
going to even do it just as if I try to
give the whole random I run down myself
tell me a little bit about sort of
what's your career and share with me a
little bit about your journey and what's
been guiding you throughout your
thinking process in your career
wow Looking Back Now it's a around 30
years I should say so but I think that
um what is the leading what was leading
me all the time and first of all
starting it will be very interesting for
me and uh related to connect to
technology and Improvement in Subway so
as I said
uh my background my academic background
I'm a information system engineer I was
I studied
as an academic Reserve yes so I studied
before the Army my service and I already
served as a in my profession I served in
a professional unit in information
security back then
and then for about uh
12 13 years I focused mainly on
Information Systems leading information
system divisions project as a CIO for in
several organizations
and then I I think it was 2001 it's the
first time I joined the industry because
before that I was in an academic
institution and in retail chain so this
was the first time
I joined an industrial plant and after a
few years as an information assistant
engineer I in my my career has changed a
little bit let's say
um and I added some more uh
areas like in supply chain planning and
Logistics and purchasing
Etc which was very much connected and
based or on my uh
previous knowledge and I think that the
fact that I came from a technological uh
basic it really it really supported it
and helped me leads the changes that I
wanted to to lead
and so
from 2007
I began my New Journey let's say as I
said in supply chain and later on in
business development
um until I even managed to lead a
startup under my
manufacturing
plan that I I worked there was a like a
spin-off from this plant that focused on
some initial product and back then it
was in the glass Industries flowplus
industry so this was a security glass
later I joined the medical device sector
which is again a big change
uh but very Global Supply Chain
leadership so so the Prof the the the
area was very similar and by the way I
can tell you now that I already saw
hundreds maybe of plants it's amazing
how much there is much similarity in the
challenges
and you can see the similarity across
different sectors I can say today so the
journey was pretty much a interesting it
is a long one yeah but I I never was I I
like to change it's over there in my
life not my husband my husband I don't
want to change but
I'm I'm a person that likes to to try
things and learn all the time so
so tell me a little bit about industry
4.0 what does that mean
um what does that mean to you what does
that mean to Ami and what you're doing
there
where are we at yeah yes maybe I should
a little bit uh describe Ami first so
Ami yeah please
and yeah let's begin with that so today
I lead as a CEO Ami Ami is Advanced
manufacturing Institute it's a National
Institute in Israel it is an
organization that is working under the
ministry of economy and Industry in fact
we are operating one of the plans to
support the industry in a minute I will
get to it and describe it a little bit
but it is a private company which is
owned by uh two
um three really entities
so we are part of teffen Consulting
Group definitely Management Consulting
Group is one of the leading the
Consulting Group in Israel with 40 years
of experience
the the second company that owns US is
a ESI which is a software house
um
the Solutions in Ai and Big Data Etc and
we have also as an ownership Browder
academic College which is an academic
arm for us this group is the one in 2019
Echo by the ministry of economy in in
industry and they established us the Ami
so this is the background regarding the
game now what we do we see ourselves as
the main focal point for industrial
plants mainly traditional and smbs we
can give the service to everyone but
this is the focus from the government
uh to lead them and support them in
their Journey towards Advanced
manufacturing or industry for in order
to improve their productivity
um and now we come to to describe what
is really industry for yeah and then
so first of all somehow sometimes people
mix the two
phrases industry 4 and advanced
manufacturing or smart Factory maybe I
don't know I'm not sure if you heard
about it
um
so first of all when we relate to
Industry 4 the 4.0 the the the reason to
call it 4.0 is because we see it as the
fourth revolution industrial revolution
as the world the first one
uh when we became industrial and the
second one of the electricity and the
third one of computers and somehow
around
2011 already
when the internet The Internet of Things
the computerize computerization became
so common and so and so much cheaper and
so much available original for us
we can define a new era of Industry 4.0
that takes all the background of
Technology of Automation and Robotics
and 3D printing and of course the
computers of force agent and enables a
factory to become end to end digital
digitalize
and when you see and so when you are
looking at Advanced manufacturing this
is what you look you look at throughout
the life cycle of the product and the
different areas of the plant and you
expect them to be a digital to be uh
integrated in between uh do you expect
the managers or the organization to take
decisions upon data and to use all what
technology has to offer so far so so
this is the area that we try to be in we
must say when that when you look at a
traditional plant
usually it is a journey I mean it's not
that you jump
from a from your current situation to
4.0 or to being end-to-end a smart
Factory it is a journey and you can take
one step after the other and we help
them throughout this surgeon so so tell
me so first of all it sounds fascinating
and uh and I think that it's you know
it's easy you know when you just go you
know it's something that is different
shifts that are happening you have to be
really be cognizant of them and think
through them in order to experience them
and to understand that we are we're
going through another Revolution and
tell me a little bit about the work that
you do working with organizations that
are making that transition and adapting
to this new world or or the new
opportunities that it provides what does
that actually tangibly mean in in your
work how does this collaboration happen
yeah yeah it is very we have a very
methodological way to to work with so
the first thing that we do when we come
to a plant that is interested in our
plan and heard about us we first
go into the plant we study it in the
first phase in order to understand all
the challenges or in the different areas
all the
opportunities that we think that they
can have that in order to improve their
process and systems and then we issue
what we call a roadmap a roadmap for
being an advanced plant enrollment for B
for implementing industry form it isn't
that I don't I'm not sure if I can share
but if you want I can share yeah that's
all I think I can
okay how do I share there's a share
button on the bottom here
Okay so
tell me if you can see it
so as I told you we go and review all
the product life cycle all the areas of
the plant you see everything from
customer and suppliers through r d and
engineering and of course the production
floor and the supply chain and quality
everything and then we present the the
picture to the to the to the management
first of all they need to realize what
is the situation we also has a maturity
index uh industry for maturity index
that we grade we have today A Benchmark
of a
260 plants that we already have gone
through this process so they are also
graded between one to five in in several
areas and the second stage is that we
share with them we build with them a
roadmap you see here yeah
she's the one pager pretty simple based
on whatever we discovered in the first
stage we list here different kind of
projects in four areas we relate to
their value chain where can they improve
and a specific for example in this plate
if you look at the color 17 a color yeah
orange for the value chain we say that
they need a a to characterize the
problem-solving processes in order to
improve their value chain or we Define
projects in production resources or in
the blue AI information system so we
list them a list of how can I stop
sharing here of
and projects that we think that if they
follow they will improve and we also try
to estimate how much so this is the the
first two stages when they get this plan
after they breath a little bit so let's
discussing inside because it's a it's a
process they need a we examine for
example the the the Readiness the
organizational culture are they ready to
lead a change
so after a short while we follow up with
them and then we begin the process of
implementing the project and in this
stage
the ministry of economy is really
supporting them with a significant
budget depend on their size Etc so they
get also our supports professional
support they get the professional
companies that we match to them to to
implement the project and they get
financial support as well so we really
have a kind of a very nice plan here
tell me a little bit about why why
you're so excited about this so what is
it about you know your work for industry
4.0 or you know the space in general
that gets you really so excited about
what you're doing here
you know last Thursday
we ran uh we had a webinar
uh in Hebrew yeah for uh just sharing we
share five different stories of
different plants from their Journey that
you asked the end and every time that
they come to a plant after a few months
a or let's see one year
and see the progress that they have gone
through and many times and it's really
exciting I mean you you really feel that
you support and uh create better work
environment a better a work experience
for the employees you hear about the
results and the improvements so of
course it's it's a great privilege and
honor to be able to lead such a such an
organization
and what is very much interesting that
it's like I don't know you we are both
Israeli and you know the phrase I'm not
sure that in English you can translate
it but
yes when you begin to eat it gets more
and more angry or you get an appetized
yeah
so that's exactly what's happening you
see many times
that a a this kind of companies I can
share with you for example a car
painting a big Carpenter yeah a wood
processing fear
uh that it is amazing they made changes
in the way their Machinery is a arranged
organized in the floor uh to create more
productivity they implemented some new
application
uh in a in their engineering team a a
one that has really improved the way
that they in shortened the time to plan
the project for the customer first and
second was integrated directly to their
machine so once they completed the
project it was issued directly to the
machines without any mistakes Etc
after a few months that we came again
and I saw they already did a great
progress we saw that they managed to
Define kpis in dashboard all areas for
several areas in the company and then
after a few another uh a period of time
then he meant it Monday Monday you know
Monday application yeah so you see
Monday dashboards on a Woodcraft plan
it's a big event I'm not saying it's a
very small one and then work with it and
they enjoy it so and and they say they
decided that every month or or so they
Define another Improvement that they're
going to to do so so it's it's really
nice to see and so those those changes
that incremental growth those step
functions that's really where you see
value and you see that excitement right
because that's uh I I love that
excitement it's
what is that how does your day-to-day
then look are you mainly in you know in
in strategy meetings is it in more
tactical advice yeah my date
my personal day today
yeah
my day-to-day
is uh consistent of meeting with
potential customers many times today for
example with two uh customers so we all
all the time go and discover more and
more of course we pay to bring them in
and to present the the plan also I'm we
are developing several courses for
example we have currently a one big
program that we call Innovation leaders
this is already running it's now we we
are going to issue our fifth problem
uh but we are issuing now a new uh
educating program called Advanced
manufacturing management manager
with our colleagues in Broward in
Browder engineering college so I'm
working a lot on marketing and this
problem uh
foreign industry industrial companies
and my colleagues and you know we are
really trying to promote it now we are
promoting it
we are running webinars everyone must
professional webinars so I'm of course
involved with that and then
I'm now working on two and
a very strategic
projects if you want one of them is
something that we are working already
two years we are working on an
experience Center a physical experience
Center so it's in the final stages that
it's already been built now we are
working on the context that we want to
present there it's going to be a a very
much the media and the digital means
there will be very much sophisticated
I'm working with the ministry of economy
to get all the relevant budget you know
it's sometimes it's a challenge
working to Define what kind of um of
technology technology we are going to
presenter so for example we're going to
present their a robotic and a robotic
assembly line to do a small line yet to
just describe the the possibilities and
how a robot can create a product from A
to Z and how it looks how does it look
the how the quality control looks like
in this kind of mechanism and some
it calls autonomous autonomous vehicle
like if you want iRobot you have an eye
robot that you are yeah
so also in Industry you know you have
for today autonomous vehicles that the
shift products for amazing coming to
another and plus well so all kinds of
these things we are working also on the
business plan there because this is
something that will not be financed by
the government so we are really working
a lot of efforts there we are calling
technological companies to join us and
to present the solution there in a
partnership model
uh so this is a huge project incredible
very much busy
and the second one I cannot call it a
project but I can say that so far we
were focused as I said in small medium
business because this is our call this
is an official from the ministry but
what happens now
is that also big companies are
um are contacting us more and more
because we grow the awareness
and of course it's a little bit
different story because the bigger the
leading companies are much more mature
and then you really have to bring them
some more of their value so I'm working
the with Jason group we are working
really on a combined program
to issue for this kind of companies uh
we are collaborating with a German
Institute there
uh so this is something I'm really I
love cooking it I'm with another uh I
really wanna thank you time and for the
energy it sounds like you're personally
so fascinated by all these different
changes and I'm sure that because of the
the incredible path in your career
having experienced so many different
things from an executive to
entrepreneurial level you got to see
these big milestone changes and how
especially industry 4.0 is impacting
companies and it sounds like you're
doing some some great work and making a
strong impact so thank you very much for
taking the time here to share this with
me very inspiring and interesting the
best of luck so much
foreign